[Music]
how many of you guys
have ever thought about i know this is
getting serious
uh have you guys ever thought about
changing your name legally
i did already i already did oh my last
name
the rest of you guys i wanted to as a
kid i hated my [ __ ] name because he
kept getting made fun of
really oh yeah would you change your
first name too first and last name just
like
i kind of did oh yeah yeah it's joe
you changed it to just joe no but not
legally
what what are you answering your
documents that's what i
kind of did what would you what would
you have changed it to i've always
wanted to probably like
john or something out of something
normal because
because because i kept getting made fun
of uh like they
they used to call me farting they called
you bartender they got my bartender and
firing
i was like just call me bro and the
simpsons came out and i'm like
yeah someone's cool named bart but then
it was still like
fart still i'm like i knew someone that
changed their last name to guitar
because he liked playing the guitar so
much wow it was on his id
yeah i knew a girl that she went from i
think it was hannah
or something to bambi should have been
hannah banana changed her name to bamboo
bambi sounds like a stripper name yeah
that's what i thought too oh yeah but
she did next on the stage we got bambi
she walks out all [ __ ] [ __ ] just
born she's not good with high heels
she slips on ice now ever since i was
little i always wanted to change my name
too i never i when i was younger i
absolutely hated my name funny yeah
i never liked it i mean you still don't
like tiffany right or it's just weird
oh the full name yeah it still rubs me
the wrong way i like hearing tiff i
don't like hearing tiffany like someone
calls me tiffany and i'm
like makes my skin crawl a little bit um
i don't know why
because he getting trouble cause the
version of yourself when everyone called
you tiffany you didn't like as much
oh do you have tony robbins i don't know
but like like for example my family
always called me thi
um like it was just i never really heard
tiffany feel like a foreign person yeah
it doesn't feel like that's me but
anyway that's beside the point i did
want to change my name though
and when i was little playing house i
would always play with my cousin
and i would always choose my name to be
naomi
who were you when you played house the
mom the dad
oh god joe's the chair i was the dog
[Laughter]
i think he was setting you up to say
some dumb [ __ ]
do you want to hear the answer yeah i do
i was always the mom the
mom because i feel like what role you
like
to play because i was either like if i
had to be a human because they were like
you can't
ruin it right i'd always be the brother
because i didn't want the responsibility
of a father
oh i was i was a dog because i was a
pervert what the
[ __ ] no because like because like i was
able to go on all the girls laps
and i'm just a dog i'm like oh i guess
that's you could be below them so
and i'm just like laying on the lap and
like all and all my friends that would
have a crush on them i'm like [ __ ]
this guy beat me too that's funny you
know they'll be like if the
if the girl they like became like the
wife then oh i'm the husband
oh i'm the doc oh that's funny can you
touch them yeah
you're like the dudes that joined the
cheerleading squad just to be with the
cheerleaders
but as like a six-year-old i think as a
kid i wanted to change my last name only
because i grew up around all the
vietnamese people
and there were just so many new ends
around that i was like i'm just like
one of a hundred people that are in this
school it's like there's so many of the
same last name how do you know you're
not related
that's what i was about to ask i'm like
did you ever have a crush on a girl and
then found out her name's nguyen and
then you're like
no it's like it's like white people
meeting someone named smith right it's
like
like how do you know or like like for
mexicans it's like garcia or whatever
right it's like
there's a lot of garcias out there
there's a [ __ ] ton of garcia but i feel
like vietnamese only have like five last
names
there's not many it's not american oh
damn like it's not
a ton you know um so
how has it happened that way like i
don't know the history of last names
there because i
all my family members like a [ __ ] and i
have
a lot they all have different last names
so growing up i'm like i don't know i
could possibly date a family member i
don't [ __ ] know
like i have a lot of family like a lot i
mean the royal family did it
that's why i went chinese i was like
yeah i don't know
this is why if you yeah you'll avoid it
completely the incest won't happen there
there's no way
but you don't get to keep it within the
family i know huh okay
all right so going back to changing
names uh this story is about a guy named
thomas
dodd and this is what he looks like
and yeah thomas dodd so he changed his
name
and he actually didn't realize he
changed his name so over the course
of the quarantine over lockdown he
started watching a lot of tv shows and
was drinking a lot
and to his knowledge he does not
remember doing this
oh actually getting his name changed you
could do that online
yeah i guess so simple i guess so cause
then one day he came back home from work
uh and there on like through the mail he
opened up a letter he thought it was a
really important letter you opened it up
congratulations congratulations where
does he live huh in the u.s
i believe the uk because he paid 89
pounds 89 pounds to get his name changed
because in the u.s you have to you have
to publicize it somewhere like on a
newspaper
that don't exist anymore what yes yes
you have to publicize it you have to go
to court
you have to get it signed by a judge
it's a long-ass process how does that
work so what do you so
you post an article like i am now this
yeah no there's like sections apparently
in the newspaper for like maintaining
this because it happened so much yeah i
mean it's the same thing with like i
think
businesses too you have to announce yeah
it's so funny because no one reads the
paper anymore
yeah gives a [ __ ] but yeah so this guy
he got his name changed
and so during corn so he thought well
maybe i changed my name because i was
watching a whole bunch of shows
and a lot of you know musical acts and
stuff and he happens to be a fan
of one particular musician and let's see
if you guys recognize her she's she's a
lot older now
but bam selena his name is celine diana
he went full-on celine dion yeah that's
funny
no more thomas no more dad it's just
silly
have you guys seen celine dion's episode
on the car
karaoke thing no she has uh
she has so many [ __ ] shoes that she
has
a warehouse full of them i think over
ten thousand or something yeah she's
like a machine that likes so there's a
ipad that she goes her ipad i mean she
goes to the warehouse
there's an ipad and she clicks it and
the shoe gets
like clueless oh yeah she could pick her
outfit crazy and she has
one assistant only in charge of just
shoes manage her shoe management dude
she was making so much [ __ ] money in
vegas though
like she wanted to leave every year and
they would up her contract
so like i'm throwing these numbers out
but i think it's like in the tens of
millions right
so it's like yeah so it's like let's say
she was offered like a 30 million
contract or whatever
and she's like i don't want to do it
next year they're like oh we'll give you
40. like they just keep bumping it up
each time she's worth it it's probably
not that high this year i think she
doesn't do it no more
she finally finally left i think cher
took over
cher yeah like sunny and share share i
think it was
people are impersonating sonny and share
no share herself oh yeah oh
the the show no he was saying share from
sunny oh i was like sonny's not around
joe yeah but she's cool though and
i never really saw her personality and
even though she's like
uh older like she has like a lot of
energy and really quirky did you see her
uh like performance at the bellagio no
just
her talking to um what's that guy's name
james
harden garden pardon corbin
corbin jordan gordon
josh corbin oh no that's a singer he's
gonna be these things
you guys you guys know what i'm talking
about but yeah
but yeah so yeah so uh celine so celine
dion
me celine dion meet celine dion and
celine dion
celine dion so celine
yeah oh my god what if celine dion's not
even her real name that's like her
statement
hilarious then he'd be the only one oh
true he needs to change him one more
time so he did it online
i don't know they said something online
yeah i want to change my name
oh maybe online only it probably is
online imagine if you come in in person
it's like getting a tattoo drunk they're
like ah get out of here you know right
right
it does say who to notify about changing
your name and i guess it could be like
driver's license and social security but
i'm like they must have the newspaper
thing over there too
maybe did a legal zoom or whatever and
they did all the they did all the
paperwork it might be different now
because i couldn't do it online like
there's a lot of things i couldn't do
online back then pandemic rules now no
like yeah we
yeah we signed up and we petitioned the
court and then i was
i think i was under 18 too when i did it
so it was even harder
oh yeah because you have to have both
parents ah maybe i forgot i mean other
countries do tend to
move faster with like technology they're
like okay we can make this online might
as well while america's probably like
i don't know we've never done that
before yo
our dmv site is like garbage
it feels like myspace technology
you know what's awesome the dmv [ __ ]
kiosks
you've been seeing them did you use them
yet it's in like every grocery store you
can renew your registration
yeah you can you can renew your
registration get get printed out on the
spot in the grocery store
what cause you know what i hate about
the dmv site you go on the site and they
tell you to call and when you call until
you go on the website
you're just going back and forth all the
time and then they make you say all the
letters of your vin
like your entire vin number which is
like a million freaking letters and
numbers
and then i'm like x and they're like did
you say
z i'm like even going in person when you
wait like let's say three hours in line
to finally get to the window
and they go oh you need to go to another
window they make you go in the back of
the line again
all over it's [ __ ] oh you gotta get
a cool
cool guy at the window sometimes they'll
be like i'll just come right back up
i'll remember you there's really cool
guys there
i got lucky then but whenever people are
like we need the government to fix this
i'm like uh if the government runs the
way the dmv does
i don't want to yeah can you can you get
triple a to fix it because they did
pretty much
to fix everything i'm down but yeah so
celine dion
um had to awkwardly tell his family that
his name
is now celine dion he couldn't just
change it back
he actually liked it he found it funny
and he's like he has no plans to change
it back
and he's kind of like we'll see how this
goes so he he's actually
have to he's had to tell his employer uh
to change his name
his mom did not find it very funny
but then he joked saying that it could
have been boris johnson and then
i'm not i'm not too aware of british
politics but apparently boris johnson
poor johnson is the
the main guy he's got messy hair oh that
guy
yeah straw hair and uh he's the uk doris
what bor donald trump uk trump yeah
so a lot not a lot of people like him so
uh so he's saying it could have been
worse could have been boris johnson
true but yeah so yeah he's not changing
his name
i feel like that's such a british thing
where they're like ah it's pretty funny
so why not [ __ ] it
i mean it's also pretty smart because
then he like this
might get him to actually meet celine
dion because it's just so [ __ ] wild
and i think that's my like what he's
holding off on and like
might i be able to meet her
[Music]
you